this is so serious that school asked me
can I think later in the day after they
continue the investigation and vetting
as you heard the chief say with the FBI
we will make a statement but not at this
time was it a broad thread affecting all
the schools or it was a broaden it was
not to one school to schools are three
schools it was many schools not
specifically identified but there were
many schools that's the reason I took
the action that I did she floated an
electronic Fred what does that mean was
a message this Martinez was already
front made the buses we know all the
buses will return to the arms this
morning what he say that there was not
threat made two buses the reason they
were returned is because we're not
picking up students it was to students
at schools nothing more than that at
this time to set school students yes
no I can't the chief after the he's met
with the city police and the FBI he will
be making further statements on why I
made the decision I made more than 900
campuses are able to say whether these
were even elementary schools i spec let
me tell you I can't take a chance and
all schools I've asked them to be
searched today by the appropriate people
and appropriate people are not
necessarily teachers are support people
if there is a problem I want our chief
of police working with the city police
and working with the sheriff to develop
a plan we have six districts to work
systematically through every one of
those schools some of them are very
large schools some of them are schools
with three and four rooms to them but I
want every school every early education
center every adult school I want them
search and a report made to me and to
the Board of Education that it is safe
many faculty members arrived early of
well before 7am are all campuses that
evacuated for anyone that was on campus
they have been told to go home what
happens to it's not the kids who may
already be at school are you telling
your parents come pick him up there or
yes there has been a connect at the
board president reviewed that with you
that they have been asked to me at a
certain gate the principal to be there
the plant manager to be there no child
to be left alone I know it is cold we're
making every effort to see that we get
the notification to parents as soon as
possible but i am not taking the chance
of bringing children any place into it
into any part of the building until i
know it's safe
in at the campuses yes that that that is
what I've done yes yes but a little
context from our parents at home how
many threats to the school district get
how really um this is a rare threat we
got threats all the time yeah what I
want to ask you yet why was this one
pitcher go ahead I just curious about
this one in particular why he got this
kind of response i think the
circumstances in a neighboring san
bernardino i think what has happened in
the nation I think what happened
internationally aya superintendent am
NOT going to take the chance with a life
of a student remember we do get
individual threats we do evacuate to
schools we do clock down schools etc and
do not release a student's until we
notify parents so what we are doing
today is no different than what we
always do accept this we are doing this
in a mass way okay are watching right
now I know those and I'm thinking to
come later today but where do we stand
for even tomorrow yeah I have no comment
on that I've told you that I will
release a statement before the end of
the day we